you have no idea Oh
I'm Selma
thank you
Oh oh this is amazing
what it was an incredible moment crush
what an 11 o'clock number oh wow you
know were like when I was first asked by
the Academy who I would like to
introduce me
I thought carefully in a I came to a
conclusion that the one person who who
really knew about my early work was
Robert Robert Osborne I mean so many so
many other legendary directors and
producers who gave me such incredible
opportunities in film they were long
gone you know I was still around but
thanks to Turner Classic Movies
and Robert those those great films are
shown and studied and discussed by
students everywhere as well as seen by a
huge general audience so thank you TMC
and thank you Robert for keeping me
alive all these years Emma
bless your heart Adelaide was a
wonderful moment for me because I had
sort of pulled out completely of
everything when my darling husband Peter
died and you by inviting me to play the
dreaded aunt Adelaide you you'd simply
helped me get back on track and I am
incredibly indebted to you for that you
know during the long course of my career
in film and television and theatre I
have known and and worked with the very
best of their time you know Ingrid
Bergman that beautiful was lovely woman
Betty Davis crazy wonderful game Kate
Hepburn oh you know I
I give her credit really for getting me
into the pot she really got me the part
in State of the Union I I don't think I
ever would have got it without her help
and you know people like awesome Wells
and Laurence Olivier and Frank Sinatra
and the Paul Newman and Spencer Tracy
James Earl Jones who I've just completed
a six-month tour of Driving Miss Daisy
in Australia wit which was a fantastic
experience and I must tell you I even
had coffee in the MGM commissary with
Clark Gable that's as far as it went you
understand I mean I don't but we were on
the lot together I want so I'm driving
down the Sunset Boulevard I never forget
in a dark-brown Mercedes convertible I
never got over it and when I could
afford it I got the same car in dark
brown and drove it for years until it
was stolen
but how would I have even begun my
career in gas like without the belief of
the great directors of that time in it
in that case of course George Cukor or
Arthur Lewin and the Picture of Dorian
Gray have been given the incredible role
of mrs. Iceland and The Manchurian
Candidate by the great John
Frankenheimer whose widow is here with
me tonight bless her heart and I'm so
proud of she is
I just couldn't top that role so I took
off for Broadway and musical comedy by
way of Stephen Sondheim's anyone can
whistle and Jerry Herman's name now
movies have cake movies have taken a bit
of a backseat since then except of
course for darling mrs. Potts and
Eglinton price but in 1984 I came back
to Universal City and I stayed around
for 12 years and playing Jessica
Fletcher and Murder She Wrote the
interesting thing is that Murder She
Wrote has given me more worldwide
attention than any role I ever played in
movies or on the stage and it's a
wonderful thing to be known in you know
in Spain and Portugal and Paris and
France and Germany and everywhere and
you know to have a whole kind of a
worldwide career that's what television
does for you if you have a hit show and
we did you know you can't imagine how
happy and proud indeed I feel really
undeserving of this gorgeous golden chap
and I I want to thank the governor's
honorary Oscar from the Academy tonight
and to be here in the company of my
beloved family and friends instead of
sitting shivering with hope and then
disappointment in Grauman's Chinese
Theatre in the nitrogen
in 60 yeah sharings this wonderful
occasion with me tonight on my twin
brothers ed crew and Bruce Lansbury who
traveled with me and our mother Mona to
this great country as evacuees from
England in 1940 and my son's Anthony and
David and my darling daughter Deirdre
and my wonderful grandchildren
Peter Catherine and Ian let me tell you
it doesn't get much better than that